Bun revenit la informatica cuantică în practică. Acest episod se va concentra pe primul și adesea cel mai
dificil pas în definirea unui program cuantic. Maparea unei probleme generale pe un circuit care poate rula pe un calculator
cuantic. Acest pas descrie cum un utilizator, pornind de la o problemă computațională
dată, o poate traduce astfel încât un calculator cuantic să o poată înțelege.
În lecțiile anterioare din această serie, lecțiile doi și trei, am discutat că etapa de mapare este primul pas dintre
cei patru din cadrul Qiskit patterns. Din acele lecții, poate îți amintești că scopul nostru era să traducem
sau să rescriem o problemă computațională ca o funcție de cost sau o valoare de așteptare
pe care o putem evalua folosind un calculator cuantic.
În lecția trei, am discutat un exemplu concret cu max cut, o problemă
care este computațional dificilă și care este frecvent întâlnită în optimizarea combinatorie.
În acel exemplu, am parcurs mai mulți pași pentru a transforma graful inițial într-o problemă nativă cuantică. Am
transformat problema găsirii numărului maxim de tăieturi în graf într-o funcție de cost, apoi am rescris acea funcție de cost
ca un Hamiltonian și am pregătit o stare cuantică de test a cărei stare fundamentală
corespunde max cut-ului. În final, am construit un circuit cuantic care reprezintă starea cuantică de test de
interes și apoi am adăugat gate-urile specifice pentru a permite stării să evolueze în timp. Această secvență de pași este ceea ce
numim mapare. La un nivel înalt, procedura este generală pentru multe alte aplicații, cum ar fi chimia cuantică
și simularea cuantică. Acum, nu putem eluda faptul că maparea poate fi dificilă. Nu există o
strategie universală pentru fiecare problemă în parte, deci poate fi intimidantă. Astăzi, voi evidenția
câteva exemple reprezentative de probleme diferite și voi descrie cum au fost mapate în fiecare caz. Voi recapitula rapid
ce am învățat despre problemele de graf, cum ar fi cele folosite în Max Cut, și voi petrece restul prelegerii concentrându-mă
pe cum să mapăm problemele care apar în natură, cum ar fi probleme de structură moleculară în biologie, probleme de structură
electronică în chimie și simularea teoriilor câmpului cuantic în fizica energiilor înalte.
Dar înainte de a petrece cea mai mare parte a timpului din acest episod analizând exemple din literatură, vreau să-ți ofer
o privire de ansamblu asupra principalelor lucruri pe care dorim să le realizăm și să le avem în vedere când mapăm o problemă. Există
câteva aspecte de luat în considerare pentru orice tip de problemă computațională care va trebui tradusă într-un circuit cuantic.
În primul rând, s-ar putea să fie nevoie să simplifici problema pentru a o face fezabilă. Acest lucru este obișnuit în majoritatea disciplinelor științifice.
Nu este specific informaticii cuantice. Dacă ai auzit vreodată expresia „presupune o
vacă sferică", aceasta face aluzie la faptul că adesea este greu să descrii un sistem exact așa cum apare. Dar
în schimb, putem face simplificări rezonabile care pot duce totuși la soluții utile.
Câteva exemple despre cum am putea face asta în informatica cuantică sunt să limităm dimensiunea sau adâncimea circuit-ului alegând un
ansatz eficient hardware sau trunchiind evoluțiile temporale complexe ori neglijând
termenii Hamiltonieni care contribuie puțin la energia finală a unei stări cuantice.
Următorul punct pe care vreau să-l subliniez este că va trebui să te gândești la scrierea problemei astfel încât un calculator cuantic să o poată înțelege.
Adesea, asta implică a pune aceste trei întrebări. Unu, ce vor reprezenta qubit-urile noastre
în acest model? Doi, problema noastră este continuă? Deoarece calculatoarele cuantice sunt digitale, va trebui să
găsești o modalitate de a discretiza problema. Și trei, în ultimul rând, topologia problemei se aliniază cu topologia
hardware-ului? Dacă da, minunat. Dar dacă nu, s-ar putea să fie nevoie să implementăm niște trucuri pentru a o face să funcționeze. Deci, să abordăm
această primă întrebare. Ce cred eu că se află în centrul tuturor dificultăților legate de înțelegerea mapării, mai ales ca
un concept nou. Ce poate reprezenta un qubit?
Qubit-urile pot fi folosite pentru a reprezenta multe lucruri. Primul și cel mai simplu, în opinia mea, este un nod pe un graf. Grafurile sunt
utilizate pentru a arăta conectivitatea în multe tipuri diferite de probleme matematice. Iar nodurile sunt un element fundamental ce reprezintă un punct
sau o entitate într-o rețea. În funcție de ce reprezintă întreaga rețea, acesta ar putea fi un oraș, o persoană sau un
feromagnet într-o rețea cristalină. Qubit-urile pot fi folosite și pentru a reprezenta bozoni și fermioni. Deși voi avertiza aici
că un singur qubit nu este exact egal cu un bozon sau un fermion. Este un pic
mai complicat decât atât și voi explica în detaliu în curând, dar în general, un lanț de spinuri care urmează anumite statistici este
ceva ce poate fi ușor tradus într-o arhitectură de qubit-uri.
Acum intrăm în exemple un pic mai complicate. Pentru aceste modele, nu mai are sens să
vorbim în termeni de un singur qubit.
În schimb, avem nevoie de grupuri de qubit-uri pentru a forma ceva fizic. De exemplu, un
grup de qubit-uri reprezentat aici pe o topologie hexagonală grea poate fi folosit pentru a reprezenta locații geometrice ale aminoacizilor
sau ale lanțurilor polimerice. Un alt exemplu este simularea împrăștierii hadronilor
în modele de fizică a energiilor înalte, care poate fi realizată prin simularea evoluției temporale a unui pachet de unde hadronic. În acest caz,
un registru de qubit-uri poate fi folosit pentru a codifica diferite stări ale unui câmp cuantic. Starea de vid a acelui câmp sau
un pachet de unde care se propagă deasupra acestui vid.
Vreau să mai menționez că maparea problemei pe un calculator cuantic are pași distincți, și anume: unu, maparea
stărilor pe qubit-uri și circuit-uri și doi, maparea funcției de cost sau a valorii de așteptare
a observabilelor și operatorilor cuantici. Vom vedea cum sunt gestionate acestea în exemple specifice. Dar în
acest moment am vorbit suficient de abstract despre provocarea din fața noastră.
Să analizăm aceste exemple acum în detaliu.
Să începem cu primul nostru exemplu. În opinia mea, una dintre cele mai ușoare probleme de mapare este cea pe care am
abordat-o deja în profunzime, exemplul max cut. În acea problemă, maparea a fost destul de ușoară pentru noi, deoarece un qubit
WEBVTT
era egal cu un nod pe graful nostru. Folosirea nodurilor pe un graf este foarte intuitivă și asta este
avantajos, deoarece corespunde multor aplicații. De multe ori, când dorești să modelezi ceva ce corespunde unei
serii de noduri conectate între ele, dacă grupările sunt binare, ca zero sau unu, sau incluse și neincluse într-un
set, poți pur și simplu și natural să mapezi aceste noduri pe biți sau qubit-uri.
În acest exemplu, și chiar în cel pe care l-am extins la 100 de qubit-uri în episodul 3, conectivitatea grafului
se potrivea deja cu topologia hardware-ului nostru superconductor. Deci nu a trebuit să ne preocupăm nici de asta. Ei bine, nu este întotdeauna cazul.
Și dacă ai un graf mai complicat sau mai conectat decât exemplele pe care le-am evidențiat până acum, va trebui
să implementezi gate-uri swap. Dar asta este gestionat de fapt la al doilea pas din Qiskit patterns, care se ocupă
de transpilare. Celălalt aspect al problemei max cut care o face atât de convenabilă este că
știm deja cum să exprimăm funcția de cost ca un Hamiltonian folosind formularea qubo.
Amintește-ți că în informatica cuantică și în algoritmii cuantici variaționali, o funcție de cost Hamiltoniană este o funcție
care codifică soluția optimă a problemei în starea fundamentală a Hamiltonianului.
Pentru a construi Hamiltonianul de cost, am putut folosi clasa sparse poly op din Qiskit pentru a specifica
conectivitatea grafului nostru, iar etapa de mapare la operatorii cuantici este finalizată. Iar circuit-ul cuantic a fost
pur și simplu ansatz-ul QAOA. Dacă nu îți sună a ceva familiar, te rog să te întorci și să verifici episodul 3, unde parcurgem
asta în mult mai mult detaliu. Acum, să ridicăm puțin nivelul de dificultate. În continuare, vom analiza
un exemplu modelat în lucrarea intitulată „Algoritm cuantic eficient din punct de vedere al resurselor pentru plierea proteinelor", scrisă de
IBM în colaborare cu Universitatea din New South Wales. Un pic de context din biochimie. Proteinele sunt
macromolecule compuse din lanțuri lungi de aminoacizi. Aceste lanțuri lungi se pliază
în structuri complexe care îndeplinesc o mare varietate de funcții biologice.
Determinarea structurii unei proteine în spațiul tridimensional și înțelegerea relațiilor dintre
structură și funcție sunt printre cele mai dificile probleme din biochimia de astăzi.
Proteinele se pliază în structuri utile datorită interacțiunilor dintre aminoacizii înșiși.
Pe măsură ce structura se răsucește și se pliază, aminoacizii care sunt departe unii de alții pe lanț pot ajunge chiar lângă
ceilalți și pot interacționa puternic. Avem nevoie de un Hamiltonian care să descrie toate aceste interacțiuni dintre aminoacizi
dacă vrem să prezicem ce structură finală va minimiza energia. Aici ne vom concentra pe lanțurile de aminoacizi și
pe modul în care pot fi modelate pe un calculator cuantic, și apoi pe cum putem obține distanțele inter-aminoacide pentru
calculul energiilor de interacțiune.
Astfel, vom fi adunat de fapt toate contribuțiile necesare la Hamiltonian pentru a-l simula
pe un calculator cuantic. În proteinele reale, aminoacizii pot ocupa un continuum de locații posibile.
Cu toate acestea, vom folosi o simplificare și îi vom restricționa la un model de rețea cristalină în care fiecare aminoacid
ocupă un punct pe o grilă. Aici, autorii au folosit o rețea tetraedrică.
O notă rapidă: codificăm direcția muchiilor și nu nodurile în sine, ca în problema max cut.
Fiecare qubit reprezintă un posibil drum de un singur pas de-a lungul grilei tetraedrice. Notează că situsurile adiacente au
fost etichetate în această diagramă ca A sau B din cauza orientărilor lor diferite în rețeaua cristalină.
Lanțul proteic este reprezentat ca o serie de viraje sau direcții pe această
rețea cristalină. Fiecare viraj dintre aminoacizi poate fi în una din patru direcții
corespunzând muchiilor tetraedrului.
Aceste patru viraje posibile sunt codificate folosind patru qubit-uri.
Sună un pic complicat. Deci, să analizăm acest exemplu cu puțin mai multă profunzime.
Să plasăm primul nostru lanț de aminoacizi în acest punct de pe rețeaua tetraedrică. Direcția spre primul
lanț de aminoacizi față de al doilea este arbitrară, deoarece sistemul poate fi întotdeauna rotit pentru a face acea muchie să indice
în orice direcție dorim. Deci, să plasăm al doilea aminoacid aici. Nu este la fel de
ușor de văzut, dar calea de la al doilea la al treilea este de fapt tot arbitrară. Toate cele trei alegeri ar
da ca rezultat două dintre muchii cu un unghi de aproximativ 109,5°
între ele. Alegerea acestei a doua muchii determină pur și simplu orientarea proteinei noastre în spațiu. Deci, fără nicio pierdere de
generalitate, putem alege primele viraje să fie doar 0 0 1 și 0 0 1
0. Cu aceste simplificări, configurația lanțului de aminoacizi este dată pur și simplu de această expresie.
Până acum am mapat muchiile tetraedrului pe qubit-uri, iar circuit-ul nostru cuantic va fi un ansatz. Acum trebuie
să luăm în considerare cum să codificăm energia problemei într-un Hamiltonian astfel încât starea sa fundamentală să ne dea modelul optim
de pliere. Acum, pentru orice configurație dată, va exista o energie asociată datorată
interacțiunilor dintre aminoacizii înșiși. Aceste interacțiuni sunt cele mai puternice când doi aminoacizi sunt
apropiați unul de celălalt. Evident, aminoacizii adiacenți în structura de bază a lanțului vor interacționa întotdeauna
între ei. Dar deoarece proteina se poate răsuci și plia, alte perechi de aminoacizi
pot interacționa de asemenea. Aminoacizii 10 și 20, de exemplu, ar putea ajunge să fie pe
situsuri adiacente după ce proteina s-a pliat. Aminoacizii care ajung în apropierea unii altora au interacțiuni
mai puternice și conduc procesul de pliere, dar nu au neapărat indici apropiați
unii de alții. Deci avem nevoie de o formulă pentru a descrie distanța D dintre aminoacizii I și
J folosind informațiile codificate pe qubit-urile de configurație. Astfel putem
folosi distanța lor de separare pentru a determina cât de puternic interacționează. Asta este un pic complicat,
dar ai răbdare, deoarece este un truc ingenios. Mai întâi, să introducem o funcție f sub a din i care indică dacă
WEBVTT
muchia a este sau nu folosită pentru virajul de la aminoacidul i. Aici, a poate lua oricare
dintre cele patru direcții posibile, în lumina codificării configurației de mai sus. Putem scrie aceste funcții și apoi putem
defini o diferență în numărul de viraje etichetate a pe rețelele A și B, de la
indexul I la indexul J, ca delta N. De ce am face asta? Ei bine, se dovedește că
rețeaua tetraedrică are o proprietate foarte utilă. Să ne concentrăm pe acest aminoacid de aici. Nu contează care anume este,
dar să-l numim aminoacidul E. Vrem să știm cât de departe va fi aminoacidul j. Și tot ce avem
sunt muchiile de-a lungul cărora fac pași structura de bază. Pornind de la I, notează că un pas
din centru de-a lungul unui tip particular de muchie, să-l numim a, de pe acest situs de rețea a
este exact opus și este anulat de un pas de-a lungul muchiei a de pe
situsurile b. Deci pașii multipli de-a lungul muchiei A de pe orice situs de rețea A mișcă
structura de bază departe de aminoacidul E, iar pașii de-a lungul tipului de muchie A de pe situsurile B
te aduc înapoi. Deci distanța dintre doi aminoacizi I și J de-a lungul tipului de muchie
pe care îl vom eticheta A depinde de diferența dintre pașii făcuți de-a lungul muchiilor A
de pe situsurile A și situsurile B. Deoarece A și B alternează în mod necesar în
structura de bază a proteinei, aceasta este capturată de termenul minus1 la puterea K. Și acest argument se aplică și altor tipuri de muchii.
Deci distanța dintre aminoacizi în pașii din rețeaua tetraedrică poate fi calculată în final cu această
expresie. Dar cum obținem Hamiltonianul din această ecuație lungă pentru distanța totală dintre aminoacizi? De fapt,
există o corespondență unu-la-unu între aceste distanțe în pașii din rețeaua tetraedrică și distanța
euclidiană. Și poți vedea că am calculat deja câteva dintre expresii pentru tine.
Aceste distanțe pot fi folosite la calculul energiei configurației tale.
În funcție de scopul tău, ai putea stabili o distanță limită sub care consideri că perechea interacționează,
sau ai putea face ceva mai complicat. S-ar putea să nu fie evident, dar am terminat de fapt cu etapa de mapare
procedând astfel. Stările qubit-urilor indică virajul, iar colecția de viraje dictează
distanța dintre orice pereche de aminoacizi. Perechile de diverse specii de aminoacizi
au interacțiuni diferite, unele atractive, unele repulsive. Dacă folosești configurația și distanța pentru a
determina pur și simplu dacă interacțiunile cunoscute ale aminoacizilor sunt active sau inactive, intensitățile acestora
sunt bine cunoscute. Nu de mine, dar le poți căuta într-un tabel, ca acesta. Deci, în rezumat, în
acest exemplu, qubit-urile sunt folosite pentru a marca locații pe o rețea cristalină care, împreună, formează un lanț de aminoacizi.
Și simulând modul în care se îndoaie și se pliază, putem spera să găsim rezultate mai bune în cercetarea medicală. Acum,
am omis cum să calculăm câțiva termeni ai acestui Hamiltonian deoarece erau specific legați de această problemă. În timp ce definirea
direcțiilor pe o rețea cristalină poate fi aplicată mai general.
Odată ce ai un Hamiltonian general, vei dori întotdeauna să-l traduci în operatori Pauli, care sunt
nativi calculatorului cuantic. Despre asta vom discuta în continuare.
Să continuăm. Acum, să explorăm cum să traducem un sistem de particule subatomice în operatori Pauli. Particulele subatomice
sunt împărțite în două categorii: bozoni și fermioni. Bozoni
precum fotonii sau bozonul Higgs urmează un anumit set de reguli statistice, iar fermionii precum electronii sau neutrinii urmează altul.
Diferența esențială dintre ei este că bozonicilor le este permis să ocupe aceeași stare. Nu există nicio limită cu privire la câți
bozoni pot fi în starea fundamentală sau în orice altă stare excitată. Fermionienii, pe de altă parte, sunt egoiști. Cer ca
fiecare particulă să aibă propria stare cuantică. Bozonicii au, de asemenea, spinuri întregi, în timp ce fermionienii au spinuri semi-întregi
precum electronul cu spin 1/2 sau particule mai exotice cu spin trei la jumătate. Pentru a
descrie un sistem de particule, avem nevoie de o descriere a energiei lor. Să ne concentrăm pe fermioni. Putem începe cu
Hamiltonianul scris în termenii a ceea ce numim operatori C. Aceștia sunt practic obiecte matematice care
corespund creării sau anihilării unui fermion dintr-o stare în sistem.
Aceștia sunt adesea scriși ca fi dagger și fi, în notația pe care o numim a doua
cuantizare. Acum, fi dagger este operatorul care creează un fermion în starea i. Fi este
operatorul care distruge un fermion în starea i. Dar ține minte că, de obicei, calculatoarele cuantice operează într-o bază de qubit
cu reguli specifice pentru reprezentarea sistemelor fermionice. Ele nu lucrează în mod inerent în limbajul
operatorilor fermionici. Pentru a depăși acest decalaj, trebuie să mapăm notația a doua cuantizare în operatori Pauli care
corespund în mod natural gate-urilor cuantice.
Există mai multe astfel de transformări pentru fermioni. O alegere frecventă este transformarea Jordan-Wigner.
Mapările Bravyi-Kitaev și de paritate sunt mai recente pentru codificările fermionice.
Operațiile bozonice, pe de altă parte, pot fi transformate folosind transformarea Holstein-Primakoff sau mapând direct
stările Fock pe o sub-bază a modurilor bozonice disponibile.
Și există și alte opțiuni pentru bozoni. Alte codificări sunt, de asemenea, cercetate activ. Dar deocamdată,
ne vom concentra doar pe transformarea Jordan-Wigner.
Deci, de ce să nu atribuim pur și simplu un qubit pentru a reprezenta fiecare electron? Ei bine, nu putem.
Qubit-urile sunt distincte, iar electronii nu sunt. De exemplu, putem eticheta și identifica ușor qubit-uri individuale pe
orice dispozitiv, dar indistingibilitatea electronilor înseamnă că nu îi putem eticheta deloc. Trebuie de fapt să etichetăm
în schimb operatorii în funcție de orbitalele ocupate, precum 1s, 2s și 2p,
în loc de electroni specifici. Astfel, trebuie de fapt să etichetăm operatorii în funcție de orbitalele ocupate, precum 1s
2s și 2p, în loc să etichetăm electroni specifici. Deci fiecare qubit joacă
WEBVTT
aproximativ rolul unui orbital în moleculă, care este fie ocupat, fie neocupat.
Dar modul în care facem asta este de fapt un pic mai complicat. Deci acum introducem ceva numit maparea Jordan-Wigner pentru a ține evidența
antisimetriei și a ne asigura că statisticile corecte ale sistemului fermionic global sunt respectate. Maparea
Jordan-Wigner este conceptual simplă din cauza corelației unu-la-unu dintre orbitale și qubit-uri. Există
și alte mapări care ating un scop similar, inclusiv maparea de paritate.
Calculul parității unei stări necesită luarea în considerare a mai multor qubit-uri. În maparea de paritate și în altele, interpretarea
unui qubit corespunzând unui orbital nu se menține.
Acum, să parcurgem împreună un exemplu destul de simplu pentru a ne asigura că am înțeles această transformare.
Să zicem că vrem să calculăm interacțiunea cu un singur qubit, f dagger f. Începem prin a substitui definițiile noastre pentru
operatorii de ridicare și coborâre. Apoi putem grupa termenii, factorizând matricea identitate i și 1/4.
Cum vedem, rămânem cu termeni care vor fi familiari celor care se ocupă cu relații de comutare. Acest termen din
paranteză nu este altceva decât i înmulțit cu comutatorul lui x knot și y. Și nu
uita de identitatea pe care am scos-o.
Acum ține minte că acestea sunt doar matrice Pauli. Deci comutatorul este bine cunoscut. Comutatorul lui x și y în
acea ordine este simplu. Este 2 i z. Asigură-te că nu pierzi urmele semnelor negative și vei obține asta ca rezultat final.
La final, am rescris cu succes o expresie fermionică în
termeni de operatori Pauli pe care calculatorul nostru cuantic îi va putea înțelege.
Să discutăm pe scurt cum am implementa maparea Jordan-Wigner în Qiskit, deoarece, deși cred că este
important să înțelegi cum funcționează maparea și transformările similare și să le vezi lucrate cel puțin o dată, nu
ai vrea să fie nevoie să faci manual toată această muncă de fiecare dată.
Mai ales pentru sisteme de dimensiuni mari în particular, putem face uz de funcția sparse poly op din Qiskit pentru a
crea ușor operațiile Pauli asociate dintr-o mapare. O implementare neoptimă
va face uz de bucle imbricate și necesită aproximativ 20 de linii de cod.
Voi lega codul aici pentru ca toți să-l explorați. Dar la un nivel înalt, pașii sunt după cum urmează.
Unu, folosește funcția sparse poly ops from list pentru a crea un operator identitate
corespunzând dimensiunii spațiului de parametri ce urmează a fi mapat. Doi, urmând definiția operatorilor de creare
și anihilare arătați anterior, folosește funcția sparse polyops from list pentru a defini operațiile Pauli x, y și z.
Aceasta va mapa operatorii fermionici de creare și anihilare pe operatorii de spin ai qubit-urilor, codificând numărul de ocupare fermionic
în baza computațională a qubit-urilor și trei, generează
Hamiltonianul dorit în baza Pauli prin aplicarea operatorilor de mai sus la orbitalele de interes. Aceasta corespunde de obicei
creării unei matrice identitate care reprezintă miezul, orbitalele neinteracționante, și apoi aplicării operatorilor de creare
și anihilare pe spațiul activ cu ponderi care corespund specificului problemei în cauză. Cum am
menționat, aceasta este doar o prezentare de ansamblu. Codul nu este totuși prea complicat și acum ar trebui
să te simți încrezător în a-l adapta la alte probleme de interes.
Acum că înțelegem pe deplin schema de mapare Jordan-Wigner, să o vedem în acțiune într-o configurație mai complicată. Poate
îți amintești această lucrare dintr-un episod anterior, despre dinamica hadronilor. Nu voi mai trece în revistă lucrarea în detaliu, dar te rog să verifici
episodul anterior dacă l-ai ratat și ești curios. În acest exemplu, maparea Jordan-Wigner este folosită pentru a
exprima Hamiltonianul situsurilor de rețea cu L situsuri pentru modelul Schwinger în absența unui câmp electric. Aici,
este mult mai greu să identifici precis ce reprezintă un qubit în acest model, deoarece doar
colecția de qubit-uri împreună formează ceva fizic. În acest context, un pachet de unde. În schimb, poți aproximativ
să te gândești la qubit-uri ca la bucăți discretizate de spațiu, unde L este volumul rețelei cristaline în care fiecare element sau
celulă unitate cuprinde două qubit-uri. Operatorii fermionici pe care i-am văzut în slide-ul anterior descriu amplitudinea
funcției de undă pe un situs particular.
Deci Hamiltonianul nostru conține acești operatori fermionici de ridicare și coborâre. Dar pentru a implementa un astfel de
Hamiltonian pe un calculator cuantic, va trebui să-l exprimăm în termeni de operatori de spin, nu de operatori fermionici.
Deci folosim transformarea Jordan-Wigner. După aplicarea transformării Jordan-Wigner, noul nostru
Hamiltonian devine această ecuație din partea de jos a slide-ului, unde sigma plus este operatorul Pauli X + I Y și sigma
minus este X - IY. Odată ce avem un Hamiltonian scris în acest format, partea
dificilă a etapei de mapare s-a încheiat și acum poate fi scris ușor într-un circuit în operatori Pauli.
În rezumat, am discutat patru exemple despre cum au fost folosite recent tehnici specifice de mapare în domeniul
informaticii cuantice. Pornind de la cel mai simplu și avansând până la aplicarea transformării Jordan-Wigner la
dinamica hadronilor. Îmi dau seama că este mult. Acest material a fost foarte tehnic
și dacă nu l-ai mai văzut înainte, poate fi foarte intimidant. Vestea bună este că îți promit că devine mai ușor și mai
familiar cu cât mai mult timp petreci exersând. Și acesta este cu adevărat miezul problemei și de aceea am numit întreaga
serie Quantum Computing in Practice.
Nu este ceva ce oricine poate pur și simplu lua și rula de la bun început. Necesită ceva studiu, ceva
zbucium și probabil momente frustrante. Dar te încurajez pe toți să stați cu disconfortul și să
explorați cu adevărat întrebările care apar pe măsură ce continuați, deoarece aceasta este singura modalitate de a învăța cu adevărat. Mulțumesc pentru
vizionare. Acesta a fost episodul 5 din quantum computing in practice. Data viitoare vom explora cum să simulăm
un Hamiltonian de la zero. Ne vedem curând.